alors on le disait emmanuel macron
reçoit en ce moment même les députés de
la majorité pour retisser des liens
après l'épisode du congé pour deux
enfants qui a laissé un fort
ressentiment
le président peut-il trouver un nouveau
souffle dans cette dernière partie de
son quinquennat
l acte ii annoncés at il explosé en vol
avant même de prendre vie c'est l'objet
de notre face à face et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec gilles casanova
consultant en stratégie et communication
bonsoir soins à vos côtés stéphane rozès
président de cap c'est le conseil
analyse et protée perspective enseignant
à sciences po et hec alors pour
commencer cette opération apaisement
le président emmanuel macron il n'avait
pas le choix selon vous où ils avaient
tous les choix de toute façon dans sa
situation il a une grande liberté dans
la mesure où elle est suffisamment
difficile pour qu'on puisse penser qu'il
n'ya pas une manière de faire il y en a
visiblement plusieurs mais la difficulté
qu'il montre c'est quelque chose qu'il
avait utilisé comme un atout d'ailleurs
que les français avaient pour un certain
nombre d'entrevues comme sympathique
il n'était pas un politique il n'avait
même pas été conseiller municipal
donc ils n'allaient pas tomber dans les
travers des politiciens le problème
c'est que il n'a du coup jamais parlé à
ses électeurs
il n'a jamais siégé dans des assemblées
il n'a jamais participé à autre chose
dans l'état que des symposiums de
technocrates qui considère que les
assemblées élues sont des empêcheurs de
tourner en rond qui empêche les gens qui
savent de faire ce qu'ils savent faire
et là il se trouve confronté au fait que
malgré tous ses efforts pour réformer la
constitution est retirée aux
parlementaires une partie significative
leurs droits cette réforme n'a pas eu
lieu
et même si le parlement n'est pas un
lieu qui a un très grand pouvoir du -
existe-t-il est il obligé de faire avec
sa majorité et il s'est rendu compte que
lorsqu'on dit à sa majorité de faire une
chose puis que le patron du medef vous
dire oh ben non ça c'est vraiment
inhumain on est obligé de dire aux
médias ouais c'est vraiment inhumain là
la majorité est bien la majorité elle ne
fonctionne pas toujours le petit doigt
sur la couture du pantalon
surtout pour une raison quand on a perdu
dont les sondages
la garantie de les faire élire stéphane
rozès vous partagez la proche de gilles
casanova justement sur cette réunion les
raisons de la convocation de cette
réunion ce soir par emmanuel macron il
ya effectivement des raisons profondes
une quinzaine de députés qui ont quitté
le groupe la république en marche dans
les 50 premières villes des dissensions
dans le tiers de ces villes
donc la majorité parlementaire et ceux
qui sont au contact du terrain ont du
vague à l'âme parce que justement étant
en contact avec le terrain effectivement
ils doivent rendre compte d'une
cohérence et d'une utilité de l'action
menée par l'exécutif
or il ya eu le mouvement social le plus
long soutenu par l'opinion jusqu'à la
fin même si c'était moi c'est important
qu'ils étaient éligibles et ajouté une
sorte de ruche a écrit qui s'adressait
au président mais dont évidemment les
députés sur le terrain du
donner des éléments d'explication mais
ce n'était pas simple et puis une
réforme des retraites toujours toujours
qui va passer du fait des institutions
mais dont toujours deux tiers des
français montrent leur opposition
donc évidemment la macro ni est en
difficulté parce que au fait c'est le
lien entre le président une pays qui
s'est délitée à partir de l'été 2010 8
alors on le sait les institutions de la
vème république donne effectivement une
grande latitude au président pour
avancer et ne sujet c'est au tour de
votre question sur le rebond c'est que
pense faire encore le président de la
république après après les municipales
on attendait cette réforme des retraites
plus tôt avant les municipales
après pardo qu'est ce que ça veut dire
que ça a été ramenée avant les
municipales
est-ce que c'était une façon d'éclusés
ou faire passer des messages ou
centre-droit donc on comprend que dans
la vision présidentielle c'est le socle
électoral sur lequel il pourrait
s'appuyer aux municipales en hameaux
dans un pays comme le nôtre l'autonomie
du sommet de détail des institutions
donne de très grande marge de manoeuvre
même si le pays peut être dans un état
de tension et de violence rarement connu
ces dernières décennies donc au fond si
le président pense aller jusqu'à la
présidentielle comme ça il ne peut user
de d'éléments de communication le sujet
csq après la réforme des retraites il
souhaite faire à nouveau une réforme
structurelle alors on va les premières
réactions à les premiers propos qui ont
été dits par le président emmanuel
macron ce soir il a exhorté les députés
la république en marche à l'unité il
s'est défendu de tout caporalisme est ce
que cette soirée de ce soir
peut marquer à un tournant un second
souffle
selon gilles casanova non il n'y a
absolument aucune raison qu'une
rencontre entre le président et les
députés de sa majorité puisse aux yeux
des français incarner un second souffle
parce que c'est pas là que se situe le
problème les français les français ils
ont vu dans ces manuels mâcon une
pochette surprise aux couleurs
chamarrées chatoyantes au premier tour
un peu plus de 15% des français en âge
de voter ont voté pour lui et au second
tour une majorité lafay président de la
république mais une majorité du pays ce
moment là à penser qu'il y avait quelque
chose à voir et à découvrir dans cet
homme qui était hors du jeu des
appareils qui était tout à fait
différent qui était autre chose
et puis au fur et à mesure ils ont
ouvert la pochette surprise et ces
derniers mois ce qui a été terrible pour
lui c'est que ce qui est apparu c'est
qu'il n'était pas à la hauteur des
espoirs
par exemple quand le conseil d'état dit
que la réforme des retraites telle
qu'elle est présentée au parlement c'est
ni fait ni à faire lorsque il retoque
profondément la circulaire du ministre
de l'intérieur pour organiser les
élections municipales
lorsque des députés de la république en
arche s'en vont les uns après les autres
lorsque des affaires comme la sphère
benalla éclate c'est autre chose que
l'orientation politique qui est en cause
c est il bien capable d'être à la place
où on l'a mis or on se souvient qu on
l'a mis pour que madame le pen n'y soit
pas du moins c'est le cas de la majorité
des électeurs du second tour et
maintenant ils se disent est ce que
c'est lui qui est capable de prendre en
main notre destin d'une façon positive
même si on n'a pas voté pour lui et ce
qui apparaît c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est
ne pas voter pour lui non plus un avis
très positif sur sa capacité à mener le
pays
est ce que stéphane rozès vous rejoignez
ce constat jill casanova qui dit au fond
1 que les couacs qu'on a pu vivre les
difficultés que la france est tentant de
livres c'est à cause du président la
république et non pas d'un entre
l'amateurisme des députés ou d'un manque
d'expérience des députés je suis
d'accord pour dire peu comme emmanuel
macron s'est fait élire dans un moment
bonapartiste ou des français
souhaitaient que les grands arbitrages
ne se passe plus dans les corps
intermédiaires ou au parlement mais dans
un lien direct entre le président et de
français puisque le français
le président on disait c'est pas vous
les français des responsables de notre
malheur vous n'avez pas intériorisé une
culpabilité ou un problème c'est le
personnel politique
je sais j'en viens et donc je vais
dépasser les anciens clivages et c'est
dans ma relation à vous que des choses
vont saper c'est la forme traditionnelle
du bonapartisme adapté aux moments
néolibérale donc on peut dire ni au
bonapartisme
alors là où je suis un peu en désaccord
avec gilles casanova sait que c'est bien
des questions d'orientation qui fait
qu'à un moment le pays n'a plus
consentis car le président macron
s'était fait élire en disant devant le
congrès le premier mandat que m'ont
confiées des français c'est de restaurer
la souveraineté de la nation
de sorte que le programme qui était le
sien était dès le départ et jugé
injustes socialement mais des français
il consentait parce que la question la
restauration de la souveraineté
nationale qui sont nationales prévalait
sur la question sociale
et quant à partir du printemps angela
merkel lui dit qu'elle ne va pas offrir
à emmanuel mâcon le deuxième étage de la
fusée qui est de desserrer les
politiques européennes pour donner des
marges
oeuvre à la réforme qu'emmanuel mâcon à
plaire car est-ce qu'en disant que la
france ne fonctionnait pas par des
réformes imposées de l'extérieur mais un
manuel mâcon revient aux propos de ses
prédécesseurs de sorte que ce qui était
accepté avant durant la réforme du
travail du code du travail ou la réforme
de la sncf que des français aucun
français ne s'opposait pas alors même
qu'il disait que la politique est
injuste socialement
ce qui était admis avant ne pouvait pas
l'être après puisque au fait il
reprenait la politique de ses
prédécesseurs que lui-même avait dénoncé
à bucarest le fétichisme budgétaire la
politique du rabot la politique imposée
de l'extérieur et à partir de ce moment
là le maquereau nisme ceux d'édith dans
sa justification première ceux qui nous
accusent étonné des observateurs c'est
qu'au fond après les chutes les jaunes
le président mâcon avec la réforme des
retraites mène une réformes
structurelles d'ampleur alors même que
son lien avec le pays est absolument
distendus il a réussi avec le grand
débat renouer un tout petit peu mais pas
suffisamment comme si au total et c'est
ça qui devrait nous interroger j'ai une
quinzaine à bas et moi comme s'il se
constatait il se contentait de constater
qu hormis marine le pen qui attend tapi
la présidentielle il n'avait toujours
pas dans le pays
d'opposition politique ou de front
syndical suffisamment fort pour faire
tenir une grève bloquant le pays comme
en 95 alors que le pineau est toujours
aux deux tiers opposé cette réforme
j va continuer d'asseoir le débat entre
marine le pen et emmanuel macron c'est
le soient c'est l'objectif
du chef de l'état oui c'est très
clairement son assurance vie politique
tant qu'il sera opposée à marine le pen
ils pensent qu'il se trouvera toujours
une majorité pour le préféré il y a
maintenant quelque chose qui entrent
dans l'équation qui est que pour être
opposée à marine le pen il faut être au
second tour or c'est cela qui
aujourd'hui devient un problème
vous avez peut-être noté que dans deux
des instituts qui mesure chaque mois la
popularité sous une forme ou sous une
autre du président de la république il a
atteint exactement le même niveau que
françois hollande à la même date de fond
de son mandat c'est à dire que s'ouvre
l'hypothèse qu'ils ne soient pas en
position de se représenter ou pas en
position de figurer au second tour
pour vous il ne sera pas je ne suis pas
voyante extralucide et tous ceux qui se
sont hasardés a annoncé que balladur
était élu que juppé était président que
bat rethel nouveaux présidents ont bien
vu que tout ça n'existait pas mais il ya
une chose que l'on peut dire c'est que
l'idée qu'il est le seul qui peut battre
marine le pen c'est une idée qui s'est
renversée c'est au contraire aujourd'hui
celui qui apparaît le plus affaibli face
à marine le pen des candidats potentiels
alors les candidats potentiels se sont
pas forcément ceux qui vont sur les
chaînes d'information dire qu'ils y
pensent en se rasant
les gens nous les joues mais des
personnes qui ne sont pas forcément
aujourd'hui dans le jeu mais qui peuvent
surgir parce qu'il ressent parce qu'ils
représentent des secteurs réelle du pays
même si ils ne sont pas forcément là
encore le produit de l'histoire des
grands partis qui sont durablement
affaibli est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
république en mars stéphane rozès est
réellement en danger
députés aujourd'hui 314 départ donc
parce qu'il ya un véritable danger pour
la majorité aujourd'hui qu'elle perde sa
majorité parlementaire sans doute part
parce que quand même il ya beaucoup de
députés qui sont conscients qu'ils ne
sont là que par la grâce du président et
que au fond dans la victoire
présidentielle d'emmanuel macron il
suffisait de mettre quelqu'un à côté du
portrait d' emmanuel macron pour qu'il
se fasse élire ce serait étonnant que la
fonte des neiges parlementaire de la
république en marche entraîne réellement
un problème par contre c'est l'état
général du pays qui est inquiétant un
état de tension un état de violences
un président qui n'est même plus à l'as
bari delà de par la saf sa dimension
symbolique qui fait qu' il peut être
interpellé
alpagué bousculé et donc la question
importante c'est le ressentiment du pays
le sentiment que les français
certes il a des vues qu'il y avait un
programme mais manuel mâcon n'a pas été
élu sur un programme il a été élu sur sa
personne et un projet le pays ne
regardait pas le programme ce qui le
regardait il consentait où ils y étaient
intéressés directement mais c'était la
posture générale qui faisaient le
consentement du pays hélas le les
français s'étaient déjà la question lors
du grand débat est-ce que les efforts
demandés aux français vise à renforcer
le modèle français quitte à faire des
efforts ou est ce un démantèlement du
modèle français et la difficulté sur le
débat sur la réforme des retraites c'est
que au fond plus le temps passe plus des
catégories sociales
inquiètes se met en mouvement contre la
réforme plus prévaut l'idée qu'en fait
cette réforme ne viserait pas
contrairement
ce qu'annonçait le premier ministre se
référant cnr de solidifier d'ancrer le
modèle mais à le débiter et du coup je
pense que il faut observer le mouvement
profond du pays car c'est lui qui fait
ensuite la cartographie électorale pour
la présidentielle marine le pen a
annoncé tout de suite elle était
candidat parce qu'elle a besoin de temps
pour continuer à faire muter le
rassemblement national de fait pour
passer du nationalisme de l'extrême
droite a plutôt une orientation
nationale une posture gaullienne
elle a fait le gros du travail lors des
européennes elle a compris que la france
n'était pas l'angleterre qu'elle ne
pouvait pas contrairement à l'angleterre
se renfermer sur elle au travers de
l'euro et donc le danger pour le
président mâcon c'est le second tour
c'est au fond est-ce qu'il retrouvera le
reflex dont il a bénéficié du pays de
peur de ce qu'incarne ou représente
marine le pen et je pense que c'est ça
qui est dorénavant entachée sssa
dorénavant la difficulté pour lui c'est
qu'il n'a plus du tout aucune garantie
en la matière parce que l acte i
marine le pen a tiré intelligemment les
leçons de son échec à la présidentielle
et surtout il n'ya plus les potasses
mélenchon qui lui avait ravi à temps le
sceptre dans les catégories populaires
du patriotisme car mélenchon a mené une
campagne en fin de campagne patriotique
et jurassiennes et après la
présidentielle
il s'est orienté vers eux je dirais une
mine plutôt gauchistes voir chez
certains systèmes islamo-gauchiste
gilles casanova est ce que aujourd'hui
le président de la république pourrait
aurait les solutions pourraient se
mettre à nouveau à l'écouté des français
notamment parlait beaucoup
la réforme des retraites on entend
beaucoup des demandes de référendum
aujourd'hui sur la réforme des retraites
on fait un référendum pour savoir si
elle doit passer oui ou non est ce que
c'est quelque chose que le président la
république pourrait entendre justement
après il y a assez peu de chance car
référendum sur la question des retraites
dans notre chose qu un non franc et
massif au président de la république
étrange manière de communiquer qui a eu
le président et le gouvernement
d'expliquer d'abord le président l'a dit
ça n'est pas une affaire d'âge
nous n'aurons pas de réponses par l'âge
puis le premier ministre a dit c'est une
infernale
c'est une réponse par l'âge déjà c'est
difficile de suivre cela mais surtout le
grand argument était c'est une réforme
qui rassemble tous les régimes pour la
justice et donc ce sera mieux pour tout
le monde et ensuite on a annoncé que les
catégories les plus proches de
l'exécutif les policiers les gendarmes
allaient en être exemptés à leur demande
puis successivement les catégories les
plus turbulentes comme les pompiers le
plus indispensable aussi en sont
exemptés les unes après les autres
si elles étaient six excellentes si
bonne si vraiment c'était ce qu'il
fallait aux français pourquoi en
exempter ceux qui sont les plus
indispensables à l'exécutif il est
évident que le message a été entendu
c'est quelque chose qui est une potion
amère et on va en exemple et ce sans
lesquelles on ne peut pas continuer à
faire tourner la machine étatique
ça n'est pas ainsi que l'on acquiert de
la crédibilité et donc maintenant il
peut dire ce qu'il veut
il est dans une situation comparable à
celle de nicolas sarkozy dans les
derniers mois il était allé faire un
discours au bureau international du
travail à l'organisation internationale
haweij pardon et ce discours était
remarquable d'intelligence de
d'élévation et et même dans ses
propositions
aucun chef d'état occidental avait fait
quelque chose d'aussi fouillé dossier
travail et il n'a eu aucun écho
alors qu'il aurait pu être applaudie par
le centre gauche
personne n'en a parlé parce que c'est la
parole qui était d'évaluer et bien là il
est dans la même situation
sa parole est dévaluée il va dire
quelque chose et tout le monde s'attend
à ce qu'ils disent autre chose ensuite
stéphane rozès il reste une minute pour
conclure est-ce que vous rejoignez le
constate gilles casanova qui dit au fond
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui c'est
terminé plus personne ne lectra je pense
que au fond il n'y aura pas de solution
de communication qui lui permettront de
renouer les choses pourraient
éventuellement il y avoir une politique
de moi ou le chaos travers d'une
dissolution pour renouer avant la
présidentielle mais sans garantie qu'il
n'y ait pas une force néanmoins par
défaut qui arrive est immergé même si
pour l'heure hormis le rassemblement
national
on ne voit pas de choses mais c'est un
peu tôt pour le rassemblement national
non comme je pense que le fondement de
notre crise nationale des raisons
essentiellement européenne c'est à dire
qu'il ya une contradiction trop
importante entre une nation qui a besoin
de se projeter et un état qui demande
d'intérioriser au contraire des règles
et des normes dans je dirais conforme à
l'imaginaire allemand
répercuté par bruxelles et bercy je
pense que la crise en allemagne peut
éventuellement donné l'idée au président
qu'au fond on pourrait peut-être faire
comme les autres pays c'est à dire
mettre d'abord notre intérêt national en
avant et que ce serait au fond pas pu
mal pour l'europe qu'elle soit je dirais
la la convergence d'intérêts nationaux
avec des objectifs européens forts et
non pas utiliser bruxelles comme une
justification de politiques dans
lesquelles au fond notre pays pour des
raisons très anciennes ne se reconnaît
pas merci beaucoup
stéphane rozès d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
président de cap enseignant à sciences
po et hec merci avoue gilles casanova je
rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
stratégie et communication